the president began his day meeting with
the man who will be the next king of
Saudi Arabia president Trump showing off
all the shiny American military hardware
that the Saudis will soon be buying but
it was Russia that quickly rose to the
top of the news the Oval Office with the
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
today President Trump revealed a plan to
meet with Russian President Vladimir
Putin we will probably get together in
the not-too-distant future so that we
can discuss arms we can discuss the arms
race talk of a meeting came after
president Trump called Putin to
congratulate him on his latest election
victory a call during which the
president mentioned nothing about
election meddling or the nerve agent
poisoning of a former Russian spy in
Britain I don't believe it came up on
this specific call but it is something
that we've spoken extensively about the
recent poisoning in the United Kingdom
that was discussed
Arizona Senator John McCain chastised
the president for the call in a
statement saying an American president
does not lead the free world by
congratulating dictators on winning sham
elections even the Senate majority
leader gave President Trump a rhetorical
back of the hand when I look at a
Russian election you know what I see is
the lack of credibility calling him
wouldn't have been hala malas the
congratulatory phone call aside the
White House today insisted it is getting
tough with Russia but said it doesn't
have much control over who gets elected
in Russia or how we don't get to dictate
how other countries operate what we do
know is that Putin has been elected in
their country the investigation into
Russian meddling got another news bump
today after President Trump added former
US Attorney Joe digenova to his outside
legal team digenova believes there was a
conspiracy against the president at the
highest levels of the FBI
there was a brazen plot to illegally
exonerate Hillary Clinton
and if she didn't win the election too
then frame Donald Trump with a falsely
created crime in the wake of Andrew
McCabe's firing from the FBI President
Trump went on a Twitter rant against the
Malheur investigation repeatedly calling
it a witch-hunt tweeting that it should
never have been started but the White
House again stated the president is
neither thinking about nor has plans to
fire Moeller Mitch McConnell gave more a
big thumbs up today I think he will have
great credibility with the American
people when he reaches the conclusion of
this investigation President Trump also
vented his frustration at sanctuary
cities today convening a group of
like-minded lawmakers and law
enforcement officials vowing a crackdown
on cities he says are violating federal
law sanctuary cities are dangerous and
we're going to take care of the problem
a president Trump waved a scolding
finger at Iran today reminding that the
Iran nuclear deal is up for another
sanctions waiver decision the last time
the President signed a waiver he
indicated that he wasn't going to keep
doing that from now until the time that
the time is over but the president
saying today when he was asked what he
was going to do about Iran said well
we'll see what happens Brett the next
chapter John Roberts live in the North
Lawn John thanks